hello and welcome to med simplified
chronic joint pain caused by arthritis
affects millions of people
across the world every year there are
different types of arthritis but
in this video we will discuss one of the
most common form of arthritis
known as rheumatide arthritis we will
talk about what is rheumatoid arthritis
what are the signs and symptoms you can
develop if you have this disease
and how is ra diagnosed and what is its
treatment
hi i'm dr umar malik and let's begin
rheumatoid arthritis is the most common
form of
autoimmune arthritis it affects more
than 1.3 million people in
america every year alone the disease
most often begins between the ages of 30
and 50. however rheumatite arthritis can
start at any age
rheumatic arthritis is an autoimmune
disease
autoimmune diseases include diseases
like systemic lupus
multiple sclerosis psoriasis sjogren's
disease etc
in these types of diseases the body's
own immune system
attacks its own cells mistakenly and
damages them
in rheumatoid arthritis the body's
immune system attacks the membranes that
cover
our joints and these are known as the
synovial membranes
your immune system is supposed to attack
foreign substances in your body
like bacteria and viruses by creating
inflammation
in an autoimmune disease the immune
system mistakenly sends
inflammation to your own healthy tissue
the immune system creates a lot of
inflammation that is sent to your joints
causing joint pain and swelling
if the inflammation remains present for
a longer period of time
it can cause damage to the joint this
damage typically cannot be reversed
once it occurs the cause of rheumatoid
arthritis
is clearly not known there is evidence
that autoimmune conditions run in
families
for instance certain genes that you are
born with
can make you more likely to get
rheumatoid arthritis
in rheumatoid arthritis our own immune
cells produce certain chemicals
and antibodies that attack the synovial
membranes of our joints
and this leads to swelling pain and
stiffness in the joints
if this condition is not controlled in
the early stages it can cause
damage to the joints that is permanent
and not reversible
rheumatoid arthritis typically affects
the joints in your hands
wrists knees elbows shoulders
and your ankles the joints affected are
usually symmetrical
meaning it affects the same joints on
both sides of the body
this is an important factor that
clinicians use to differentiate
rheumatoid arthritis from osteoarthritis
which is another very common type of
arthritis but the joint pain in
osteoarthritis
is usually asymmetrical
rheumatic arthritis can also affect
other organ systems in your body
about 40 percent of people who have
rheumatoid arthritis
also experience signs and symptoms that
don't involve the joints
other than joints it can affect your
eyes your skin
the gastrointestinal tract it can also
affect the heart
the blood vessels kidneys and lungs
before discussing about the signs and
symptoms of rheumatoid arthritis
let's first take a look at some of the
factors that increase the risk
of rheumatoid arthritis you have high
risk of developing
rheumatoid arthritis if you are aged 60
years or above
if you are a female because females have
higher
risk of autoimmune diseases if you have
specific genetic traits for rheumatoid
arthritis
if you are suffering from obesity you
also have higher risk of rheumatoid
arthritis if you smoke tobacco
or even your parents smoke tobacco when
they were children
rheumatoid arthritis symptoms are
different for each person
some people have long periods of
remission with few
or no symptoms others develop severe
pain
and stiffness episodes that can last
from a few weeks to many months
new and earlier treatment is changing
the overall picture
of rheumatoid arthritis more people are
having low disease activity
or even going into remission promoted
arthritis usually affects the hands and
feet first but it can occur in any joint
it usually involves the same joints on
both sides of the body like we discussed
common symptoms include stiff joints
especially upon
getting up in the morning or after
sitting down for a while
or after prolonged activity increased
stiffness early in the morning is often
a prominent feature of the disease
and typically lasts for more than an
hour
gentle movements can relieve the pain in
early stages of the disease
these signs help to distinguish
rheumatic arthritis from osteoarthritis
in osteoarthritis early morning
stiffness is less prominent
your affected joints also become tender
meaning there is pain when you press
your joints
the joints may feel warmer and may even
have color changes related to
inflammation
as they can seem a bit reddish
rheumatic arthritis can also cause
generalized symptoms like fatigue
muscle pains poor appetite and a
depressed mood
now like we discussed rheumatoid
arthritis can also affect
several parts of your body other than
your joints let's look at what signs and
symptoms you can develop
if rheumatoid arthritis affects your
skin you can get
rheumatide nodules these are bumps under
your skin
most of the time they aren't painful and
they move easily when you touch them
about one in four people with rheumatoid
arthritis get these skin bumps
they usually develop on your elbows but
they might show up
on other bony areas like the underside
of your forearm
your acne tendon or the tendons in your
hands
rheumatic arthritis can also damage your
lungs
or the membranes covering your lungs
this causes chest pain that
worsens with breathing lung problems are
the most common symptoms of rheumatoid
arthritis outside the joints
you might notice shortness of breath
upon minimal activity
or if rheumatoid arthritis remains
active for a long time
it can cause pulmonary fibrosis which is
hard to treat condition that makes it
tough to breathe
likewise rheumatic arthritis can inflame
the lining around your heart or your
heart muscles
you probably wouldn't notice symptoms
from that at first
but later on in life there's a chance
you could feel
shortness of breath or sharp stabbing
pain in the chest
it can also raise your risk of heart
failure atrial fibrillation
and stroke with age rheumatic arthritis
can also cause
inflammation of your blood vessels it
can show up as spots on the skin
or can also cause ulcers in more severe
cases
so these were some of the signs and
symptoms you can develop if you have
rheumatoid arthritis
your physician may order some lab tests
to confirm the diagnosis
of rheumatite arthritis these tests can
include the erythrocyte sedimentation
rate
and c-reactive protein higher levels of
esr and crb
indicate excessive inflammation in the
body
a a or antinuclear antibody test
and anti-ccp also known as anticyclic
citrullinated peptide test
are also done which can indicate the
diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis
rheumatic factor antibody test is also
done which can indicate
rheumatoid arthritis but not everyone
with rheumatoid arthritis
tests positive for ra factor
x-ray or mri of a joint can help to
identify
what type of arthritis is present x-rays
can show
how much joint damage you have and mri
can give a more
detailed picture of your joints apart
from these
specific tests your doctor can also
order basic tests like a complete blood
count
kidney and liver function tests as
rheumatoid arthritis can affect multiple
organs
now let's discuss how is rheumatoid
arthritis treated
and how you can manage your symptoms on
a daily basis
if you have rheumatoid arthritis now
rheumatoid arthritis is a disease which
has been present since
ages and many different types of
treatments have been used in the history
but with incomplete results or even
serious side effects
in 1897 a german chemist felix hoffman
started using
acetyl salicylic acid or aspirin to
treat various forms of arthritis
but taking aspirin for longer periods of
time caused serious side effects
like blood clotting disorders and
stomach ulcers
in the 1930s even injectable gold was
used as a disease modifying drug for
rheumatic arthritis
gold showed some success with years of
use
and is still a component in a number of
disease modifying drugs
used even today but
in today's modern era the treatment of
rheumatoid arthritis is much more
developed
with introduction of newer and safer
disease modifying drugs
with few to no side effects the first
line of drugs that are used for the
treatment of rheumatoid arthritis are
known as
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
these drugs include diclofenac
acyclofinag
ibuprofen naproxen endometrin
etc as you can tell by their name
these are anti-inflammatory drugs
meaning they decrease the inflammation
or the swelling that occurs in the
joints due to rheumatic arthritis
this reduces the pain and tenderness and
also helps in prevention
of long-term damage to the joints
the second category of drugs that are
used are steroids
these are used when you do not get a
good relief from
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs or
if you have
advanced rheumatoid arthritis
steroids reduce the pain and
inflammation in the joints
and can play a very important role in
slowing down joint damage
but they cannot cure rheumatoid
arthritis
steroids are especially useful for acute
symptoms
or short-term flare-ups of rheumatoid
arthritis
long-term use of steroids can have
serious side effects
these include cataracts osteoporosis
glaucoma
diabetes mellitus and obesity
the most important category of drugs
that are used for treating rheumatoid
arthritis are known as disease modifying
anti-rheumatic drugs also known as
demarts
d-marts can slow the progression of
rheumatide arthritis
and prevent permanent damage to the
joints
and other tissues by interfering with
the overactive immune system
it is most effective if a person uses it
in the early stages but it can take from
4 to 6 months to fully experience the
benefits
some people may have to try different
types of disease modifying drugs
before finding the most suitable one
the most common demarts that are used to
treat rheumatoid arthritis
include leplunomide methotrexate
sulfasarazine minocycline and
hydroxychloroquine
side effects vary but may include liver
damage
bone marrow suppression and lung
infections
and since these drugs have to be taken
for lifetime
the side effects of these drugs can be a
serious issue
that is why recently many newer types of
drugs have been developed for treating
rheumatoid arthritis
one such category of drugs are known as
biologicals
also known as biologic response
modifiers
now like we discussed in rheumatoid
arthritis
your immune cells produce certain
chemicals that play a role in damaging
your joint membranes
which lead to symptoms like pain
swelling and tenderness
one such chemical is tumor necrosis
factor alpha
also known as tnf alpha tnf alpha
causes the release of other inflammatory
chemicals
like interleukin-1 and interleukin-6
these interleukins in turn lead to more
inflammation
and bone and cartilage destruction
therefore
drugs were developed which specifically
target the tnf chemical
and these are known as anti-tnf alpha
drugs
these include infliximab adalimumab
and etanercept since these drugs lower
the activity of your immune system
they increase the risk of infections but
these drugs do not have serious
long-term side effects like
most of the other medicines used for
rheumatic arthritis have
but these are costly and not everyone
can afford them
biological drugs are used most
effectively
when they are combined with a
non-biological drug such as methotrexate
one important thing to consider before
starting biologicals
is to test for a latent tuberculosis
infection in your body
because these drugs can cause a latent
infection to reactivate
recently a new class of disease
modifying drugs are being used for
rheumatoid arthritis
known as janus kinase inhibitors or jack
inhibitors
if you have rheumatoid arthritis your
body makes too many proteins known as
cytokines
which play an important role in
inflammation
some cytokines attach to receptors on
immune cells
and signal the immune cells to make even
more cytokines
jack inhibitors stop this process by
blocking the messaging pathway
this slows down your immune system
activity and helps to decrease your ra
symptoms
these include drugs like tophacetinib
and paracetamol
older drugs don't always work for
everyone
only about 65 percent of people who take
disease modifying anti-rheumatic drugs
get relief from their symptoms if you
are not in this group
a jack inhibitor might make a difference
in one study
about half of the people with rheumatic
arthritis who didn't improve with
biological drugs
had symptoms that were less severe after
they took jack inhibitors
to facetime for three months
another advantage of jack inhibitors is
that you can take them
by mouth you must inject biologicals
such as adalimumab
into your skin while other disease
modifying drugs for rheumatoid arthritis
are given intravenously into your
bloodstream
but you can take jack inhibitors as a
pill
so this was about the medical treatment
now let's take a look
at some of the lifestyle modifications
you need to implement if you have
rheumatoid arthritis
because lifestyle modifications like
exercise and diet are very important to
manage your symptoms
and disease activity
for people with rheumatoid arthritis
exercise can be very beneficial for
relieving pain
and joint stiffness and it can be
particularly helpful during a flare
of ra people with rheumatic arthritis
who exercise regularly
report that they have less pain than
those
who do not exercise exercise can reduce
painful symptoms improve joint function
and flexibility
it also increases the range of motion
and also boosts your mood
i will leave links to some of the useful
videos and articles
that explain what types of exercises you
should perform
and how to do them make sure to check
them out in the description box down
below
people with roommated arthritis should
avoid sternus exercise or any exercise
that causes joint pain
these may include high impact exercises
that put
excessive strain on your joints
so friends i hope you found this video
helpful and informative
if you did you can support math
simplified by subscribing to our channel
you can also join our patreon community
where we share patreon only exclusive
content like health tips
diet charts behind the scenes of our
videos and much more
thank you so much for watching see you
in the next video